President Trump says the US should be
very careful about who was allowed into
the country from the Bahamas after
hurricane Dorian I don't want to allow
people that weren't supposed to be in
the Bahamas to come in to the United
States including some very bad people
and some very bad gang members and some
very very bad drug dealers this comes as
a Bahama the Bahamian government rather
struggles to house thousands of
displaced people who arrived in the
capital which by the way is on an island
about the size of Cincinnati it was
spared the worst of the destruction
Nicki batiste was in Nassau which is the
capital Nicki what are you seeing gal
well day after day here at this port
evacuees are streaming off ferries
coming from some of the hardest hit
islands and many have nowhere to go
meanwhile back in the communities
they've left behind recovery workers are
trying to get a grasp on the death toll
which is now risen to 50 piece-by-piece
in the hot sun urban search-and-rescue
teams in some of the worst hit areas of
the Bahamas are combing through enormous
piles of debris in the wake of Hurricane
durian joined by Bahamian government
workers they're continuing the grim task
of recovering victims bodies we've
probably hit at most one tenth of this
area and we found five human remains I
would say based off of our sample size
we're gonna see more the work is slow
and tedious much of it is being carried
out by first responders from the US it's
not clear exactly how long many of them
intend to stay but some told us they're
here for the long haul
we're here to to the end to as long as
our departments feel of the need for us
to go back the majority of the deceased
have been recovered from hard-hit Abaco
island during our visits there we saw
some survivors who had to leave without
knowing if their loved ones are alive
they're being evacuated by plane and on
ferries most with no more than a
suitcase of the little they have left is
your home completely gone everything
here
I don't have nothing else we talked with
some survivors on the five-hour journey
we took with them to Nassau for so many
like Carlene Smith where life goes from
here is unclear do you think you'll ever
come back to Abaco I don't think it's
gonna be they're gonna be in a hurricane
the Department of Homeland Security says
the u.s. embassy here in Nassau is now
open for emergency visa appointments
every Bahamian citizen must have a valid
passport and a travel visa if they're
traveling to the u.s. Tony
Nicky batiste on the ongoing crisis in
the Bahamas Nicky thank you very much